the law of total expectation will give
us another important tool for reasoning
about expectations and it's basically a
rule like the law of total probability
closely related to it really for
reasoning by cases about expectation so
it requires a definition of what's
called conditional expectation so the
expectation of a random variable our
given event a is simply what you get by
thinking of replacing the probability
that R equals V by the probability that
R equals V given a so it's the sum over
all the possible values that are my take
of the probability that R takes that
value given a ok with that definition we
can state the basic form of the law of
total expectation which says if you want
to calculate the expectation of R you
can split it into cases according to
whether or not a occurs it's simply the
conditional expectation of R given a
time's the probability of a plus the
conditional expectation of R given not a
times the probability of not a so it
really looks as the same format as the
law of total probability now of course
it generalizes to many cases so the
general form would say that I can
calculate the expectation of R by
breaking it up into the case that a one
holds times the probability of a one the
case that a two holds times the
probability of a 2 through a n and this
couldn't very well and typically is an
infinite sum where the AI is of course
our partition of the sample space so
there are all the different cases either
a 1 or a 2 or a 3 they're disjoint and
altogether they cover the entire set of
possibilities well let's use this as to
get a nice different and simpler way
more elementary way of calculating the
expected number of heads and n flips so
let's let a of n be the expected number
of heads and n flips no just shorthand
for because the notation will be easy to
work with then writing capital e
brackets of H n so what do we know about
expectation of n well I can express it
in terms of the
spec patient of the remaining flips so
if I if I have n flips to perform
they're independent then if I perform
the first flip something happens and
after that I'm gonna do n more flips and
the expected number of flips is going to
be the expected number I'm the remaining
n minus 1 plus what happened now well if
I flipped ahead first then I've got a 1
as adding to my total number of heads
and then I'm gonna do n more flips so
the expected number of flips is going to
be that 1 plus the expected number on
the rest of them if the first flip was
not a head it was a tail then the total
expected number of heads is simply the
expected number of heads on the rest of
the flips and these are two cases where
I can plot apply total expectations so
by total expectation the expected number
in n flips is au 1 plus en minus 1 times
the probability of a head plus en minus
1 times the probability of a tail well
now we can do it a little algebra
multiply through here by pay that
becomes a pay and this becomes a P times
en and minus 1 so I've got en minus 1
times pay and en minus 1 times Q
remembering that P plus Q is 1 this
simplifies into being simply en minus 1
plus P well this is a very simple kind
of recursive definition of en because
you can see what's going to happen
subtracting 1 from n adds a P so if I
subtract 2 from and I add another pay I
get to-- pay and continuing all the way
to the end by the time i get to 0 I've
gotten n times P and I've just figured
out what I wasn't familiar with already
we which we previously derived by
differentiating the binomial theorem the
expected number of heads and n flips is
n times P but this time I got it in a
somewhat more elementary way by
appealing to total expectation